thing that I got mad at the other day
speaking of poetry it's kind of spoken
word
I was watching online Ari Shaffir did
you know his this is not happy he has it
his own comedy show wait to tell stories
I've done I've done it before
yeah but I saw one where he did it
before I've ever done it
Bobby Lee and I go get a prostitute now
he never called me and said hey can I
tell the story about us getting a
prostitute I thought you did it with him
no he just not that story hey Bobby but
we've talked about I understand its
principle baby because if you would have
called me he said hey can I tell the
story about yeah I'd be like yeah all
right you know I mean permission but
just the thought that he just you know
mean did this crazy story about it's
funny story yeah you know I mean but
it's like it makes me seem disgusting
you are disgusting there's no other
better word to describe even disgusting
you are that I'm what I totally get why
what do you mean City you're your
disgusting creature whoa
you are as am i that's why this works
together that's what exists well let's
go say in what way I mean I don't think
that you getting a prostitute is
disgusting I just think that I'm what I
mean disgusting not in a negative way
it's more like you do [ __ ] that the
average person wouldn't get into for
example give me example he was 69 he
would with we know family members okay
stop stop okay
yes I did 69 with a family member and it
happened to him be a man a boy but that
was a key I was a kid yeah and is it
because I talked about it then I'm
discussing orbiting I actually did that
I mean a lot of kids have done weird
things that they would never talk about
like I don't George I don't know what
he's done
but I know he's done some [ __ ] crazy
[ __ ] in his personal life yes you have
yeah you did yeah you did George but
overall you are just disgusting like
even with hygiene though let's keep it
real okay all right that's what this is
about being real yeah and this is about
me on honestly looking myself in the
mirror and going okay let's let's find
out who I really am all right so tell me
all you need to do is take this camera
and then see your side of the bed what's
on your side of the bed
sunflower seeds I love them three-year
old banana peel delicious smoothies he
has just let dry out fermenting like
implementing like yeah I mean just fish
guts that's wrong we did that as a job
and that's wrong there's never been fish
that's on the side of my bed all right
oh go inside this car actually it
straight up smells like horse manure and
I can't figure out why I ride horses I I
take I took this car to get washed I
interior and exterior and right after
that it still smells like [ __ ] animal
manure and I can't figure out why and
it's because it's just years and years
and years it was like fermenting
whatever in there maybe you're right at
me I don't know I don't know how to
change that about myself
hygiene wise yeah just I'm just a dirty
dirty person
and I've always have been and it's like
I've I've gotten by this far for being
you know you know what you don't have
though or body odor thank you I was
gonna say and that's a fact and that's
real that's what we've learned legit
does not his armpits never smell do you
sweat though rarely interesting
not for my pits but can I say this I
have been to other comedians as houses
famous ones yeah and I don't want to
name names okay
and ten times worse than my situation
Jim Jefferies no I don't think so true
there's other ones okay I'm not gonna
name names I'm just saying okay and then
there are ones that I I've been to their
houses before they became famous yeah
and then when they became famous they
can get like you know I mean the maid
service they service and all that stuff
yeah
so I'm not the only one it's a common
thing maybe I think it's just a you know
I think there's a lot of creative people
that would that were like that I don't
think Lou Reed probably had a beautiful
place maybe I don't know maybe what is
that name of that book George the art of
tidying up it's like a it's like what is
it George tell me Eve Ali won't even
talked about it honours yeah I know it's
off the Facebook is it the Facebook
woman that made it I wrote them no no no
it's different no that's another one but
it's the art of tidying up or something
to that effect and maybe you might feel
inspired by the book and maybe you
should pick it up don't read it last
time you read a book yeah that's not
that it is that I've done fine by living
my life the way it is okay I never paid
taxes I'll say that just shut up don't
say he has now I have now but I didn't I
don't pay parking tickets I don't do any
of that I don't do anything I don't do
anything you know I mean if I take a
shower I do it
for funsies but other than that I'm just
gonna live the way I have a beautiful
girlfriend cuz I look young I never stop
working
I'm always picking [ __ ] up cleaning
scrubbing oh it just never ends for me
[Music]